it's really it's really disheartening
first bite treats in ottawa's byward
market started the year off with a
lockdown then the protest convoy
descended on nearby parliament hill the
financial toll is painful as people and
delivery services shun the downtown core
business has been
to be frank
pretty tough the rito center ottawa's
largest mall with 175 shops has been
closed since the weekend affecting
thousands of employees and neighboring
businesses mall owner cadillac fairview
says the continued closure of an
important community space loss of
employment income and financial impact
on clients is heartbreaking given our
shared pain and sacrifice during the
pandemic
costs for the city of ottawa run 800 000
for policing plus 1 million in city
services every day the city's asking for
help from the provincial and federal
governments including 1800 more officers
which would bring daily policing costs
to two and a half million dollars
for context security for a canada day
celebration runs north of six hundred
thousand dollars this eclipses that
lingering uncertainty about how long
this drags on means long-term damage to
tourism hospitality and retail as
visitors stay away even if they leave
next week could they be back in a month
could they be back in two months
with cross-border traffic disrupted at
the ambassador bridge between windsor
and detroit the busiest land connection
for canada u.s trade and blockades
causing delays at the american border in
and around kutz alberta analysts expect
the price of goods trucked in to go up
the longer this continues especially
food and that's on top of existing
supply chain related inflation
the rcmp tells global news they don't
yet have a tally of policing costs to
taxpayers but they'll have one soon this
could be a major disruption
if the government can't find a way to
bring this back under control and unite
everybody politically socially and
economically anne gaviola global news
toronto